[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und marietta slomka
beim streit um die gasanlage geht es ja
weniger um die unterstützung als solche
sondern um das wie relativ unumstritten
ist dass der staat nicht zulässt dass im
zuge der gaskrise und putins zugetreten
hennen eine der wichtigsten versorger
hierzulande bleibt geht und damit
womöglich auch reihenweise stadtwerke in
die knie gehen dann würde es in
deutschen wohnzimmern nämlich auch sehr
schnell sehr kalt
gestritten wird aber darüber ob die von
wirtschaftsminister habeck auf den weg
gebrachte umlage die richtige methode
ist fließen damit am ende auch hilfen an
unternehmen die gar nicht in not sind
klaus brodbeck berichtet der mensch und
das schwitzen robert habeck besuch einer
verzinkerei in gelsenkirchen heute
nachmittag ins schwitzen bringen den
betrieb sommer plus 400 grad vom
flüssigen zink plus sorgen um energie
und explodierende preise den minister
selbst erhitzt wohl eher der streit um
seine gas umlage und die frage wieso
auch gut verdienende konzerne dabei
kassieren könnten
wir sehen aber natürlich auch viele
trittbrettfahrer ist jetzt gibt so war
es natürlich nicht unmittelbar mit
gesagt die die menge ist nicht besonders
groß aber wir prüfen noch einmal ob man
außer
anfrage ist dass man wirklich nötig
nicht auch noch mal
eine regelung findet dies diesen
unternehmen schwerer macht zum beispiel
dem österreichischen konzern omv
auch unterwegs im deutschen gasgeschäft
auf seiner internetseite feiert das
unternehmen fette gewinne im ersten
halbjahr
sondereffekten von 5,6 milliarden euro
auf anfrage teilt omv heute dennoch mit
es habe ausgleichsansprüche als
gasimporteur im sinne des gesetzes
bekanntgegeben ob und in welcher höhe
ansprüche bestehen und ob diese in
anspruch genommen werden hängt von
weiteren prüfungen und entscheidungen ab
allein die möglichkeit bringt das
politische berlin auf die barrikaden und
die koalition der ampel unter stress
minister haben muss ganz klar machen
dass mit der gasanlage und auch mit
steuerlichen unterstützung nur
unternehmen geholfen wird die auch
tatsächlich unsere hilfe brauchen ich
denke der wirtschaftsminister ist hier
in der verantwortung und er ist
derjenige der jetzt nach schaffen sollte
an dieser umlage denn in der aktuellen
form ist sie nicht fair und ich meine
wir sollten hier alles unternehmen damit
wir faire maßnahmen ergreifen und alle
menschen auch verstehen können warum
haben wir diese umlage eingeführt und
wem hilft sie tatsächlich sie hilft den
menschen und den unternehmen in diesem
land aber dafür muss sie eben nur auf
die unternehmen zugeschnitten werden die
in wirtschaftliche schieflage geraten
sind wenig hilft da dem grünen
wirtschaftsminister dass ihm seine
parteivorsitzende zur seite alt mit
einem vorschlag den in der ampel rot
schon mal gemacht und geld gleich
abgelehnt hatte eine situation wie hier
hat wohl recht und gerechtigkeit
auseinander klaffen dann braucht es
politische lösung und deshalb ist für
mich die logische konsequenz aus dieser
situation eine über gewinnt steuer für
energiekonzerne
klingt komisch ist aber so die weniger
gas je höher der preis desto heißer wird
der herbst gilt für robert habeck wann
immer
es ja die gaskrise allein genügt
eigentlichen um graue haare zu bekommen
aber wir haben ja auch noch eine reihe
anderer sorgen inflation steigende
zinsen fachkräftemangel und nicht zu
vergessen die pandemie nachwirkungen wie
zb lieferprobleme in allen möglichen
branchen man kann da eine ganze liste
herunterbeten aber dann kommt doch heute
die meldung dass die deutsche wirtschaft
trotz allen zugelegt hat das
bruttoinlandsprodukt ist im quartal
april bis juni gestiegen valerie haller
das ist ja durchaus überraschend wie
erklärt sich das nun es hat tatsächlich
viel mit corona zu tun und dem
weitgehenden ende der beschränkungen in
diesem zusammenhang stütze war nämlich
vor allem der konsum die menschen haben
wieder mehr geld ausgegeben für
restaurantbesuche freizeit und das
reisen und davon haben im frühling und
sommer die dienstleister profitiert und
hinzu kommt dass auch der handel mit dem
ausland insgesamt zugenommen hat im
ergebnis heißt dass die deutsche
wirtschaft wächst wenn auch minimal im
zweiten quartal um 0,1 prozent im
vergleich zum vorquartal
auch die kassenlage des fiskus hat sich
deutlich verbessert nach corona mehr
steuereinnahmen vor allem von
unternehmen und gleichzeitig weniger
ausgaben für wirtschaftshilfen und
kurzarbeit alles gut für den
staatshaushalt
aber wenn man ökonomen richtig versteht
dann wird das so nicht bleiben oder nein
vermutlich nicht ein alarmsignal ist
nämlich die schlechte stimmung in den
chefetagen
die industrie leidet unter den
gestiegenen herstellungskosten das liegt
natürlich an den hohen gaspreisen aber
auch an den bekannten logistik problemen
wie zum beispiel das niedrigwasser im
rhein und die sorge ist dass sich einige
firmen die teure energie auf dauer nicht
leisten können und einige fabriken sogar
dicht machen müssen auch dürfte der
private konsum als konjunkturmotor
ausfallen weil die hohe inflation
natürlich die budgets der menschen
belastet und all das zusammengenommen
das sind keine guten aussichten die
zeichen stehen auf rezession die frage
ist nur noch wie stark und wie lange
dankeschön bei der wiener frankfurt über
die wirtschaftliche lage energiekrise
und staatshilfen debattiert nachher auch
maybrit illner mit ihren gästen darunter
der bundesfinanzminister
unterdessen hat der verursacher des
krieges und seiner folgen angekündigt
seine armee aufzustocken putin will mehr
als 100 30.000 zusätzliche soldaten
die musste allerdings erst mal finden
und er wird sie nicht im russischen
kernland in moskau und sankt petersburg
suchen dort möchte man ungerne
massenhaft zinksärgen in empfang nehmen
das könnte trotz aller propaganda dann
doch auf die stimmung schlagen
während in der ukraine weiter zerstört
und gestorben wird wie befürchtet war
der gestrige nationalfeiertag auch am
tag schwerer russischer angriffe in der
hebestreit berichtet aus der ukraine
der angriff traf den kleinen jacqueline
aus heiterem himmel kurz nach 13 uhr
kamen die raketen die erste darauf ein
wohnhaus und zerstörte umliegende
gebäude für seinen elfjährigen sohn kam
jede hilfe zu spät
niemand hat ihn hier vermutet wir
dachten die explosion habe ich ihn
vielleicht aufs dach geschleudert aber
er lag hier hätten wir das früher
gewusst aber niemand hat ihn hier
vermutet
ob der verzweifelte vater erinnert dass
wenige minuten später noch mehr raketen
kamen wer weiß aber diese trafen wohl
das eigentliche ziel des angriffs diesem
zug und dem die russen behaupten er habe
ukrainische soldaten ins kampfgebiet
richtung front transportiert wir haben
es nicht kommen hören
plötzlich gab es eine explosion und
alles fing an zu brennen
für die eu ist diese angriff mit seinen
vielen toten nichts anderes als
russischer raketen terror der zu dem
passt was sich rund um das atomkraftwerk
buschehr abspielt russlands angriff hat
eine der größten nuklearen anlagen
europas zum kampfgebiet gemacht am
mittag gab es rundherum in den besetzten
gebieten plötzlich weder wasser noch
strom im später veröffentlichte die
ukrainische betreibergesellschaft eine
nachricht die versichert wir haben zum
ersten mal sah borussia komplett vom
netz nehmen müssen grund sei dass auch
die letzte von vier leitungen aus dem
kraftwerk heraus durch die kämpfe
beschädigt worden sein genug strom für
den betrieb der anlage sei aber
vorhanden alle systeme liefen normal
bleibt das kraftwerk vom netz
abgekoppelt kann die ukraine keine strom
nach europa exportieren
engpässe bei strom und gas seien der
preis für die unabhängigkeit europas
meint kiels bürgermeister vitali
klitschko im zdf interview
es wird nicht einfach aber denke ich mal
gemeinsam wiese stark um diese
herausforderung würden wir
fixieren und verlieren haben sie nicht
angst dass die deutsche unterstützung
verloren geht
glaube ich nicht weil ich habe schon
gesagt es geht nicht nur interesse
lokale es geht nicht nur unsere
unabhängigkeit es geht auch in interesse
in deutschland es geht um europäische
werte
menschenrechte pressefreiheit
demokratischen werten am späten abend
dann die mitteilung der eu das
atomkraftwerk buschehr ist wieder mit
einer leitung angeschlossen und
ukrainische netz liefert aber noch
keinen strom
der krieg beherrscht die deutsche
außenpolitik direkt oder indirekt dass
annalena baerbock heute in marokko zu
besuch ist ist zwar zunächst mal der
tatsache geschuldet dass diese
problemzone des auswärtigen amtes einer
lösung bedurfte die beziehungen zwischen
deutschland und marokko waren auf einem
absoluten tiefpunkt marokko hatte sogar
seine botschafterin aus berlin abgezogen
die hintergründe erklärt gleich andreas
künast sehr mit der ministerin nach
rabat geflogen ist in den deutsch
amerikanischen beziehungen musste
jedenfalls etwas geschehen zumal in
deutschland ja über 200.000 menschen mit
marokkanischen wurzeln leben aber
angesichts des krieges gibt es noch mehr
geostrategische und energiepolitische
gründe marokko einen besuch abzustatten
so ein bild muss den marokkanischen
fotografen noch ganz unwirklich
vorkommen außenminister buch etat gibt
außenministerin berbalk die hand marokko
gibt deutschland die hand nach endlosen
monaten des streits man kann auch sagen
der offenen feindschaft so sieht die
versöhnung aus und so hört sie sich an
liebe kollegin einmal nach so kann und
vielleicht lerne ich beim mittagessen
dann außer in schale noch ein drittes
wort
der konflikt den deutschland mit marokko
ausgetragen hat ist der konflikt den die
halbe welt mit marokko austrägt ein
gewaltiger ungelöster gebiets konflikt
seit fast 50 jahren beansprucht marokko
fast das gesamte territorium seines
südlichen nachbarn der westsahara kein
land der welt hat diese aneignung
anerkannt außer den usa eine der letzten
verfügungen dass da bereits abgewählten
präsidenten job als deutschland
daraufhin eine sitzung des
un-sicherheitsrats einberuft ist
marokkos regierung außer sich beendet
fast jeden kontakt wird die flagge an
seiner botschaft in berlin ein und zieht
die botschafterin ab obwohl die neue
bundesregierung dieselbe kritik übt wie
die alte reicht dem königreich das
berbalk sie etwas anders formuliert
plötzlich und ein bisschen überraschend
ist alles wieder gut
den könig
wir müssen zusammenarbeiten in alle
sektoren
wie unnachgiebig marokko sein kann bekam
zuletzt vor allem spanien zu spüren als
die marokkanischen behörden
unangekündigt die grenzkontrollen
aufhoben und hunderte flüchtlinge die
exklave melilla und zehnter stürmten es
gebe einen klaren und einfachen maßstab
für das verhältnis zu anderen staaten
hatte erst am wochenende könig mohammed
der sechste gesagt die haltung zur west
sahara
die deutschen die nun wieder nach rabat
reisen haben auch prioritäten
klimaschutz flüchtlinge aber vor allem
energie marokko gilt als zukunftsland
etwa für grünen wasserstoff
insgesamt können uns nie wieder abhängig
machen von ländern die unsere werte
nicht teilen das zahlen wir gerade
dieser tage mit einem hohen preis es
muss den diplomaten beider länder noch
ganz unwirklich vorkommen dass sie
wieder miteinander reden von seinem
vorgänger hat der deutsche botschafter
robert berger nur das allerschlimmste
gehört kein kontakt keine einladung kein
anruf ab sofort herrscht wieder
diplomatische alltag marokko ist wieder
da
und jetzt geht es erstmal weiter runter
damit den nachrichten
solidarität mit ukrainischen soldaten
hat bundeskanzler scholz bei einem
besuch auf dem truppenübungsplatz putlos
in schleswig-holstein demonstriert dort
werden die soldaten sechs wochen lang in
der bedienung des flugabwehr panzers
gepard geschult im gespräch mit
vertretern des rüstungskonzerns
krauss-maffei wegmann den ausbildern an
den panzern und ukrainischen soldaten
äußerte scholz anerkennung und
bekräftigte deutschland werde weitere
schwere waffensysteme an die ukraine
liefern darüber hinaus fordert die fdp
mehr lieferungen aus beständen der
bundeswehr
der von der bundesregierung eingesetzte
unabhängige experten rat für klimafragen
hat deutliche kritik an der umsetzung
des klimaschutzgesetzes geübt die
bisherigen sofortprogramme für mehr
klimaschutz im verkehrs und
gebäudebereich reichten nicht aus
deutschland verfehle seine klimaziele
vor allem die pläne von verkehrsminister
wissing seien schon im ansatz ohne
hinreichenden anspruch
wenige wochen vor den kongresswahlen in
den usa will präsident biden eines
seiner wahlkampfversprechen einlösen
millionen hochschulabsolventen müssen
ihre studienkredite nicht mehr komplett
zurückzahlen je nach einkommen sollen
ihnen jeweils 10 bis 20.000 dollar
erlassen werden in den usa sind die
studiengebühren zum teil sehr hoch viele
absolventen starten hoch verschuldet in
ihr berufsleben
im nordosten von syrien hat es mehrere
militärische auseinandersetzungen
zwischen us streitkräften und
pro-iranischen milizen gegeben zum
zweiten mal innerhalb von 24 stunden
bombardierte die us-luftwaffe deren
stellungen dabei sollen drei vom iran
unterstützte kämpfer getötet worden sein
die angriffe seien reaktion auf
koordinierte raketen schläge der
pro-iranischen milizen auf us stellungen
in der region
fünf jahre nach der vertreibung der
ruhiger aus ihrer heimat dem überwiegend
buddhistischen
gibt es noch immer keine perspektive für
die menschen tausende haben heute in
bangladesch für bessere
lebensverhältnisse demonstriert und die
möglichkeit zur rückkehr sowie die
bestrafung der verantwortlichen
gefordert
2017 waren hunderttausende ruin vor der
gewalt durch das militär ins nachbarland
geflüchtet vor dem internationalen
gerichtshof wird mir einmal völkermord
vorgeworfen
der rechtsextremist der den kasseler
regierungspräsidenten walter lübke
ermordete muss für lange zeit ins
gefängnis und kann nach verbüßen der
freiheitsstrafe in weitere
sicherungsverwahrung genommen werden
aber war er wirklich der einzige theater
und war es seine einzige tat nicht nur
die familie von walter lübke hatte daran
große zweifel und beantragte nach dem
urteil eine revision doch ausreichend
beweise gegen den mitangeklagten ließen
sich nicht finden wie auch für den
verdacht dass lüpkes mörder jahre zuvor
bereits ein attentat auf einen jungen
iraker verübt hatte zu dem schluss kam
heute der bundesgerichtshof christian
von rechenberg richtet
kaum hatte der vorsitzende richter
jürgen schäfer begonnen sein urteil zu
erklären da machte er einen
bemerkenswerten anschoben erinnerte an
familie lücke an ihr trauma an ein leben
das nie mehr so sein wird wie zuvor
die eindrucksvollen worte die frau braun
lücke in diesem zusammenhang vor vier
wochen hier in der revision
hauptverhandlung gefunden hat werden in
erinnerung bleiben das war respektvoll
und wirkt zugleich wie ein verzeihung
der bgh kann nur rechtsfehler prüfen und
die art wie das oberlandesgericht
frankfurt die beweise im fall lipke
bewertet hatte
ist fehlerfrei
seine schlussfolgerungen brauchen nicht
zwingend zu sein es genügt dass sie
möglich sind es bleibt also bei
lebenslang für stefan ernst markus h
hingegen ist vom vorwurf mord helfer
oder mittäter zu sein frei gesprochen
auch wenn so der bgh heute sinngemäß das
olg frankfurt letzte zweifel an haas
beteiligung nicht ausräumen konnte eine
solche exzessive erörterung würde die
möglichkeiten und ressourcen der
gerichte über steigen ohne dass jemals
absolute vollständigkeit erreicht werden
könnte sie ist daher von rechts wegen
nicht zu verlangen das olg frankfurt
durfte sogar den wichtigsten zeugen
nicht glauben stefan ernst der tischte
dem olg damals drei unterschiedliche
versionen seiner tat auf die erste
version empfanden die richter als
plausibel doch als ernst markus h als
helfer belastete war er unglaubwürdig
das hat der bundesgerichtshof heute
bezeichnet als eine differenzierende
beweiswürdigung das kann man so sehen
ich würde eher sagen das ist eine
gespaltene beweiswürdigung die ist
möglich aber dafür muss es überzeugende
gründe geben familie lüttge hoffte bis
zuletzt auf eine neue verhandlung wollte
wissen was in den letzten sekunden im
leben des ehemannes und vaters passiert
war
diese entscheidung bedeutet das eine
weitere aufklärung der tat nicht mehr
erfolgen wird viele offene fragen zum
tatablauf bleiben wahrscheinlich für
immer offen
zugleich gilt aber auch dass walter
lübke ein leben lang für den
freiheitlich demokratischen rechtsstaat
eingetreten ist mit all seiner
überzeugung und mit all seiner kraft und
zu dieser haltung gehört auch eine
solche entscheidung wie sie hier vorhin
verkündet worden ist eine solche
entscheidung zu akzeptieren auch wenn es
sehr schwer fällt und so hinterlässt
dieses urteil letzte zweifel offene
fragen und nachdenkliche experten markus
hart bleibt ein freier mann auf
bewährung familie lübke und der andere
erfolglose nebenkläger müssen mit dem
schlussstrich aus karlsruhe nun
leben
es ist bitter das zu sagen aber erst der
mord an einem deutschen cdu politiker
schien manchen endgültig die augen zu
öffnen welche gefahr welche gewalt vom
rechtsextremismus in deutschland ausgeht
dabei war das schon sehr lange so nur
dass fast alle opfer der vorangegangenen
jahrzehnte unbekannte menschen mit
migrationshintergrund waren und nicht
hochrangige funktionsträger der
deutschen gesellschaft der terrorist ns
etwa dessen taten lange zeit als döner
morde bezeichnet wurden oder der terror
in rostock lichtenhagen
1992 gegen asylbewerber und
vietnamesische vertragsarbeiter
und unübersehbar war damals auch auf
welch fruchtbaren boden dass dort viel
nicht viele leute dem gewalttätigen mob
zu jubeln bernd mosebach erinnert dann
diese geschehnisse vor und 30 jahren
frank walter steinmeier mit einer
sonnenblume vor dem sonnenblumenhaus
eine schlichte geste als zeichen der
erinnerung an ein ereignis das sprachlos
machen könnte der bundespräsident hat
die macht des wortes und er wird klare
worte finden am ende eines tages indem
das land auf dieses haus schaut sowie im
august vor 30 jahren
molotow cocktails geworfen von
radikalisierten jugendlichen aufgehetzt
von neonazis angetrieben vom applaus des
mobs viele rostock oz und darunter auch
angereiste trittbrettfahrer die polizei
zieht sich am abend des 24
august zurück warum ist bis heute nicht
geklärt im haus vor allem menschen aus
vietnam von den brandstiftern nach oben
getrieben letzte zuflucht das dach
wolfgang richter rostocks
ausländerbeauftragter ist mittendrin und
0 endete
alle können sich retten wie durch ein
wunder gibt es keine toten dafür viele
verletzte verletzten körper und seele
nicht erleben ab immer wieder
unterstützung von deutschen menschen so
dass ich sagen kann ich vertrauen keine
deutschen mehr
hab dann ist mein glauben an den staat
irgendwelche weggebrochen 30 jahre
aufarbeitung und die suche nach dem
warum unfähigkeit von politikern
hilflosigkeit von ordnungshütern in
frage stellen rechtsstaatlicher und
moralischer werte in mehr als 60 inter
kulturellen projekten engagieren sich
rostockerinnen und rostocker für
demokratie und toleranz nicht
nebeneinander leben sind nun miteinander
und zusammenleben friedliche miteinander
zusammenleben und die
unterschiedlichkeit zu erkennen aber
diese unterschiedlichkeit einfach auch
noch zu setzen es ist viel erreicht
worden in rostock vieles bleibt noch zu
tun ob man geht einfach nur die straße
entlang und wurde durch angemacht aber
das passiert halt nicht nur in rostock
das passiert in frankfurt das passiert
in münchen und stuttgart also diesen
alltagsrassismus erleben wir halt
überall darauf kann man sich nicht
verlassen nur weil in dieser stadt so
ein ereignis gewesen ist gibt es keinen
automatismus das muss man sich jeden tag
wieder neu erarbeiten die
zivilgesellschaft die vereine die
institutionen und die politisch
verantwortlichen gemeinsam am abend die
rede des bundespräsidenten dem rostocker
rathaus rechte gewalt auch nach
lichtenhagen sei viel zu lange nicht
ernst genommen worden verzicht auf hetze
und gewalt sei bürgerpflicht wenn eine
gesellschaft unter veränderungsdruck
steht dann ist der weg der
radikalisierung
noch kürzer weil er vermeintlich
einfache lösungen anbietet ich würde
sagen vorgaukelt die einfachste aller
lösungen ist die suche nach einem
vermeintlich schuldigen es gilt für uns
alle wachsam zu sein
für h feine risse im zusammenleben
wehrhaft gegen die feinde dieser
gesellschaft und
friedfertig im umgang miteinander
vor allem aber solidarisch mit den
bedrohten wir dürfen sie
niemals im stich lassen das ist die
lehre aus lichten halten
das zdf team das ich damals in dem
wohngebäude befand und das alles hautnah
miterlebte hat diese dramatischen
stunden später in einer ausführlichen
reportage geschildert ein zeitzeugnis
und diese original zdf sendung vom 25 08
1992 finden sie bei uns online in der
mediathek
und jetzt nochmal bundes landet ganz
andere themen
in istanbul sind die gruppen für die
anstehende fußball champions league
ausgelost worden für fünf bundesliga
vereine und ihre fans sehr spannend in
der gruppe b trifft bayer leverkusen auf
fc porto atletico madrid und club brügge
aus belgien in der gruppe c spielt
bayern münchen gegen den fc barcelona
robert lewandowskis neuen verein inter
mailand und den tschechischen meister
viktoria pilsen in der gruppe d bekommt
es eintracht frankfurt zu tun mit
tottenham hotspur sporting lissabon und
olympique marseille
in der gruppe f trifft rb leipzig auf
champions-league-sieger real madrid
schachtjor donezk aus der ukraine und
celtic glasgow und in der gruppe g
spielt f der bvb dortmund gegen den
englischen meister manchester city fc
sevilla und kopenhagen in der europa
conference league stand am abend für den
ersten fc köln das playoff-rückspiel
gegen ferrer war fc in ungarn an die
kölner machten ihre heimspiele
niederlage wett und gingen mit einem 13
0 auswärts als sieger vom platz die
gruppenphase ist erreicht
bei der lufthansa ist ein erneuter
versuch gescheitert die von den piloten
angedrohten streiks zu verhindern das
vom konzern nachgebesserte lohnangebot
hält die gewerkschaft vereinigung
cockpit immer noch für unzureichend
einig ist man sich wohl über ein
gehaltsplus von 5 5% gestritten wird
weiter über einen automatischen
inflationsausgleich in
lettland ist das sowjetische
siegesdenkmal in der hauptstadt riga
abgerissen worden gegen scharfen protest
aus moskau auf weisung der städtischen
behörden wurde der 79 meter hohe obelisk
zum einsturz gebracht in lettland müssen
wegen des russischen angriffskrieges
alle objekte demontiert werden die
totalitäre regime verherrlichen dazu
zählte speziell auch das sowjetische
siegesdenkmal das so der lettische
staatspräsident ständige erinnerung an
die besatzung war und damit an
repressionen
das was von uns gleich nach dem wetter
geht es wie schon angekündigt bei
maybrit illner weiter und gegen 0.50
melde ich mich noch mal mit unserem
heute schon mal update bis dahin wieder
sehen
[Musik]
guten abend jetzt kommt bewegung ins
wetter und das liegt zum einen an dem
tiefen keller das zieht morgen weiter
nach osten und gleichzeitig kommt diese
schwül-warme gewitter luft aus
südosteuropa zu uns und so gibt es dann
morgen gewitter von schleswig holstein
bis nach bayern schon heute nacht gibt
es die ersten schauer und gewitter ganz
im osten sonst sind viele wolken
unterwegs und die temperaturen sinken an
der mosel auf 20 grad da wird das also
noch mal eine tropische nacht deutlich
frischer wird die nacht an den alpen mit
elf grad morgen gegen die
höchsttemperaturen ganz im osten bei 24
bis 27 grad ungefähr zwischen hannover
und dem oberrhein wird es dagegen fast
überall noch mal heiß mit 29 bis 32 grad
das ist nämlich ungefähr die region in
der es morgen vormittag noch am längsten
sonnig ist im westen westlich des rheins
com allerdings schon die ersten
regenschauer und dann geht es dieses
band morgen vormittag etwa zwischen der
lüneburger heide und der donau es schon
die ersten kräftige schauer und gewitter
gibt und die weiten sich dann am
nachmittag aus die ziehen ganz langsam
können also örtlich eng begrenzt
durchaus stark regen mitbringen dort
drohen dann überschwemmungen ja solche
überflutungen in unwetter in gibt es am
samstag dann noch hier im osten
deutschlands danach beruhigt sich das
wetter von westen am montag liegen die
höchsttemperaturen bei 20 bis 28 grad
wie sie hier am trend für stuttgart
sehen können stürzten die temperaturen
ab von morgen auf übermorgen um 8 grad
temperaturen von 25 grad gibt es in der
kommenden woche dann kaum noch guten
abend